LeBron or Curry LeBron your favorite
Pokemon Pikachu John Cena The Rock The
Rock Ronaldo or Messi Ronaldo anybody in
the league that's gonna Tire surpass Tom
Brady with the championship wins
somebody please God what do you think
the Jets record is gonna be this year
11-6 someone you want to meet that
you've never met Randy the Macho Man
Savage the very lucky black cat or the
Red Devil they're very very very very
very lucky black cat you just dropped
the song with Snoop Dogg do you plan on
doing another song with another artist
yes favorite wine of all time 1947
chevell Blanc how many blueberries do
you eat a day on average three because I
probably eat like 20 like every seven
days that's [__] awesome thank you so
much Gary man